i keep hearing about bitcoin bridges to
avalanche what is that what are people
talking about when they say that they
are bringing their bitcoin uh to one of
these ecosystems
so
there's a basically when you're talking
about bridge you're talking about
different types of bridges but
basically you're
enable people to bring assets over from
a different chain onto
you know one chain to chain number two
and allow the functionality that you
have on chain two that perhaps you may
have different experience from chain one
so there's a ethereum to avalanche
bridge that thing has generated over 60
billion dollars worth of assets moving
back and forth over time
and now there is a bitcoin bridge so
people who want to huddle bitcoin but
use defy they have the ability to do
that through this bridge
and when that happens like what is the
at a high level the technical uh kind of
mechanics of this is it bitcoin and it's
being wrapped in some other uh kind of
token is it literally bridging over and
there's like support uh for bitcoin or
whatever like how does that work
right so there's two different or three
different methods okay one way you're
describing is the wrapped concept where
you have it on one end and then you have
another one called the wrapped aversion
on the other end there's another way to
do it is really you can have you know
stuff on one side being locked but then
you have a native version of that on the
other end that acts as the same thing so
it's not necessarily any different
you're just minting a new
uh
asset whether it's btc or whatever it is
there's two general ways of bridging
across one is the wrap like you talked
about and the other is actually just
locking the asset value on one end and
creating the same asset or a native
version of that asset on the other end
and when that happens how much
functionality uh is gained or lost like
it's interesting to think about let's
take bitcoin as uh one example and then
maybe we'll use ether as another example
so bitcoin uh may not be as expressive
or kind of have as much of the smart
contract functionality uh as maybe an
eth has
when you see that do you lose or gain
functionality in either one of those
situations when you do these bridges
that's a great question and generally
speaking from the user's perspective
you're gaining more functionality
regardless of whether it's the wrap
version or the native version to another
chain because you're doing that either
because one side is too cheap or too so
sorry too expensive you needed to
transact cheaper or there are different
applications on a different chain
um
so the user's perspective is you're not
losing functionality you do it because
you actually gain functionality where
you can't do it on the previous chain
from the um chains perspective obviously
you increase activity and liquidity so
it's a it's kind of like a win-win the
you know the ones that are secure and
are able to do this well and have uh you
know assets that are you know secured to
the user will ultimately win in these
cases
got it and so when you think of uh kind
of avalanche why are people bridging
these assets over there what's like the
value proposition to doing that versus
like keeping bitcoin on on bitcoin
network or something
yeah i mean for bitcoin specifically
there there's less functionality but in
general especially avalanche's case you
know there's over a thousand
applications on the chain it's uh
instant finality it's super fast there's
lots of dapps in d5 um as well as uh
gaming applications so just a lot of
utility and functionality for bitcoin
users who may want to keep their bitcoin
because they think the price is too low
but also get to use the functionality
associated with a chain like avalanche
so
let's kind of keep going down this
rabbit hole because it's actually pretty
interesting to me um
on bitcoin
there would be two i would say scaling
solutions uh and this can be super
generalized right but there's like layer
two solutions like the lightning network
and then there's kind of side chain
things liquid and a bunch of others um
this is sounds like it's almost like a
third uh
value proposition that people would make
is like hey you could take the asset you
could bridge it either natively uh or
kind of in a true bridge in a rapt way
uh and then you could gain speed
efficiency innovation whatever
do you see those as competitive to like
the layer twos and side chains or is it
just something that's different and kind
of just
two different questions there's like
side chains and layer two specific to
like you know lightning specific to
bitcoin and then there are layer twos
that exist in the call it you know evm
compatible type ecosystem um reality is
in the long run i think there's going to
be a lot of interoperability among many
many different chains and that's really
where uh we all really deep down if you
are honest yourselves that's where we
want the space to go to
um layer twos you know they provide
certain functionality but they also
are not able to provide necessarily a
lot of decentralization and the security
that a uh layer one can
but they do you know they're more
centralized so they can probably be
cheaper and faster in some respect so
there are different trade-offs but
over time i think it's about where the
community where the applications are and
there will be multiple winners and who
and then the interoperability is what
really the power of
the permissions world of blockchain that
we all want where people can actually
own their data and profit from their you
know data and have low switching costs
so over time there will be a few or
maybe more than a few winners but there
will be interoperability
and when you
look at that the interoperability
argument um there's people and i think
in every ecosystem that would say like
no we don't want to interoperability you
know there's some sort of maximalist
view or whatever
what's your kind of vision of that
interoperable world like why do you say
that that is what we want
well let's reduce this argument to the
most basic level like web 2 in my
opinion
scale we've all benefit from certain
efficiencies but the infrastructure on
certain level operates
very poorly from interoperability it's
basically silo data databases monolithic
databases
everyone has to constantly update it
themselves you have to create apis and
permission who gets into where and what
and then you have to over time you have
to reconcile that so you have a
gazillion intermediaries and a lot of
middleware that's built and you allow a
lot of centralization and people who get
bigger have a lot of power over the
the the new entrance to anything so over
time what happens is like look at swift
network it's supposed to be a non-profit
but it takes five days for you to send
money from the us to an international
friend it's those intermediaries and the
painful middleware
and uh other things related to that that
causes that delay so
if you have a permissionless world where
there's seamless and chains out there
like avalanche that are instant
settlement instant finality payment uh
and settlement happens very close to
each other or at the same time and when
you have this decentralized public and
mutable type situation suddenly you're
unlocking trap value
basically you know look at the swift
network or look at credit cards what
you're doing is you have one
counterparty to another waiting
basically for the validation that those
transactions are real and while it's
waiting for 30 days at the
bank for to pay the merchant at the
restaurant you are literally taking
money out of the system by having it in
a permissionless world where things can
move smoothly
and fast suddenly you are literally
making money more productive so
increasing the velocity of money and
effective actually even growing the
economy i mean you know gdp is money
supply times velocity of money
so when you start to look at other use
cases uh what else are you excited about
like where else is this technology going
so
obviously d5 is something that avalanche
is very excited about and if we look at
d5 2.0 when we come out of this call it
winter and we have spring
really excited about a couple of things
because for d5 to really explode and to
grow
you need new participants to come into
the ecosystem and that means tokenizing
real world assets and ultimately having
some sort of identity mechanism
on chain identity mechanism so that you
can really enable that
representation of a person or a thing
properly because if you look at d5 1.0
i think everyone in the crypto world
will agree that it actually the d5 apps
function pretty well given you know all
the stuff we hear from the c5 type
players
no one got their withdrawals halted
transactions continued code was the law
and it all happened sure was painful
these you know ave maker compound lost a
lot of tdl but they functioned and
everyone got their money in fact you
know it did pretty well in my opinion
however
the basic mechanisms to allow that were
the smart contract code you know rules
embedded into the code and the over
collateralization
so in d5 1.0 to get to d5 2.0 which we
all want which is to bring new users in
you can't use a system where you're over
collateralizing with existing crypto
assets that means just people who are
already in the system who have assets
are able to use the system
no new collateral comes in means no new
people coming in so in order to get new
people to come in you need less
volatility in that asset we try to deal
with stable coins in the crypto native
but if you tokenize real world assets
that inherently is less stable you also
invite new players in but to do that
especially with financial services firms
you need so some sort of proper kyc aml
and identity associated with it so we
are really excited for real world assets
that will be tokenized to grow the whole
d5 pi for everyone it seems like every
uh
kind of blockchain every ecosystem is
trying to do this so uh obviously uh the
ether and the ethereum ecosystem of
thailand's a long time i've seen solana
pitches uh bitcoin with the tarot
protocol built on top of lightning
avalanche et cetera does it matter where
stuff gets built uh like you know if i
use google i couldn't tell you what the
technical architecture is i just know i
type question in a box and i get an
answer uh and google you know it's cool
to me this answers my question uh like
is it ultimately going to be not the
world we all want to go to where the
underlying anything under the hood is
completely abstracted away um i think
actually the fun part right now is
trying to build and create and be one of
those players in order to do that but
yes the end result will be like your
stuff is served in aws you have no idea
whether it's aws azure or google cloud
and um one day you just google it and
you can do it and you abstract away the
entire of everything under the hood when
i drive my car i could not fix the
engine
but i know how to drive a car that's
literally where we want to get to but
right now it's a lot of fun and it does
matter a little bit right now because
there are differences in technology
differences in speed and scale and
differences in
value propositions so i think in the
long run or medium term the ones that
have better evaluation a better value
propositions will ultimately win out but
to the user in the long run it doesn't
really matter
abstract it away